[Musica]
e vi basta andare a prendere la scatola
è buffo sarei sparito per sempre
la mecca di questa
[Musica]
le mie chiavi e toni decreti che il no
che cosa era questo rumore berlino
hai visto qualcosa dentro una scatola
che cosa c'è dentro
bravo
no berlino no no no non mettere l'auto
testino dentro alla scatola ok può
essere pericoloso vi ricordate tutte le
cose che sono uscite da questa scatola
che è meglio non aprirla dentro magari
può tirare fuori solo le ramo che ne
dite
vediamo ok che cosa vorrà dire questo
non merlino chiudila spero che non
voglio dire che è arrivato un nuovo
nemico
abbiamo appena sconfitto la maledizione
del lupo mannaro è già arrivato un altro
nemico che nemico può essere con delle
foglie una formica gigante questa
berlino ci sono telefonate non si mangia
bene le io perché non vi sempre a
mangiare tutto proprio come vitale
ascoltami bene merlino ci sono delle
fonti e poi per terra forse dobbiamo
seguirli ma non dire niente abita da gil
di capitale che dite secondo voi
dovremmo seguirle queste foglie e dopo
li fai finta di niente come sempre
perché altrimenti mi caso dovrei dei
grandissimi guai è stato troppo curiosa
abbiamo visto abbiamo le foglie pronte a
berlino si salito a proteggervi vero il
percorso delle forze budino fino qua e
marley no no no non devi mangiare il
ramo per istituire le porte vuol dire
che dobbiamo andare in questo tipo
simone
[Musica]
il percorso delle foglie finisce qua
quindi vuol dire che deve uscire qua in
giardino controlliamo bene il giardino
vediamo se c'è qualcosa o qualcuno
tenete gli occhi aperti anche poi
sentiti a chi voi questi rumori strani
meglio non avvitare vitale ancora perché
altrimenti mi direbbe perché ha aperto
la scatola di nuovo non l'avrei dovuta
aprire come sempre state cielo luna
piena
ma non è più un problema per me perché
bella hanno trovato qualcosa che cos'è
ma è un limone e dove schiavi berlino
berlino mi avrebbe dovuto aiutare a
trovare qualcosa ma ha trovato un limone
non mi farò impaurire da questa nuova
creatura o qualsiasi cosa sia quindi
continuerò a cercare i fermati quel coso
e merlino mourinho allontanati berlino
alla fine si è rivelato il più
intelligente come sempre ho capito che
cos'è
c'è uno spaventapasseri dovrei parlarvi
è immobile non si muove beh in effetti
gli spaventapasseri non si muovono
proviamo andare a parlargli non paura
tanto di te mister intruso
spaventapasseri so che sei uscito dalla
scatola in più al mio bodyguard e
berlino
accanto allo spaventapasseri non si
muove e noto che è uscito fuori dalla
scatola e se io ti rimette dentro la
scatola fari dai perfette e mi possa
andare a prendere la scatola e sarei
sparito per sempre
che poi scappa scappa ma allora non è
solo uno spavento bot
beh direi che la cosa migliore da fare
adesso è tornare dentro casa e avvisare
vitale presto e ha chiuso la porta qua
nel mie chiavi e tommy vee vediamo che
tu capisca chi scappa
senti si può sapere che cosa vuoi da me
so che ti ha mandato qualcuno per la
maledizione della scatola paura potresti
andartene per favore vabbè come non
detto io ci ho provato almeno i ragazzi
ho avuto un'idea sono nascosta acqua
addirittura questi poli o questo
bastoncino che tirerò in testa allo
spaventapasseri sperando che lo metta ko
secondo me funzionerà lasciate un mi
piace per portarmi fortuna subito
quatt'occhi staff ozil dei pizzini
[Musica]
gli spaventapasseri non fai paura mi
anche i passeri vieni qua sta nel
coraggio che cos'è quella
beccati questa
il piccolo ha funzionato
no era meglio non card o
[Musica]